hi everyone I'm Daniel and I'm Billy and
we're from the Google cloud developer
relations team our focus is on storage
and especially cloud-based storage we
want to help you make informed decisions
about what storage solution to use for
your iot project we're going to start
off by discussing a little bit about the
shape size and scale of the data every
industry has unique data problems and
we're going to focus on the kinds of
problems that you might see when
building IOT apps at scale then we'll
see why the cloud is a great fit for
data of this shape and scale and we'll
look at how to ingest your data into the
cloud we'll akeem we look into a number
of storage characteristics that you need
to take into consideration when
reasoning about storage solutions and
finally we'll examine a few common use
cases and real-world scenarios that
businesses encounter or map those
business needs to technical storage
requirements and then select a database
based on that information and we've got
a cool we've got a few cool demos for
you to check out today so this is a
storage talk although with a little bit
of a cloud twist and one of the first
things to come to mind that comes to
mind when we think about storage is how
much data can I store this is a relevant
question especially in the with an IOT
use case in mind connected devices today
produce massive amounts of data
according to statistics a billion
connected devices by 2023 so this is a
map of oil and gas fields in the Gulf of
Mexico let's do a thought experiment
let's say that we have 1300 oil and gas
fields and each oil and gas field has a
thousand sensors streaming data even if
those devices is only streaming a
hundred bytes per second that still
makes 137 megabytes per second in total
or
eight gigabytes per minute or 11.5
terabytes a day you could try to manage
that infrastructure on your own but
there's a reason the cloud exists all
the infrastructure headaches that comes
with managing
massive amounts of data is minimized by
using the cloud so let's make sure we
are on the same page here when we talk
about IOT data what we really talk what
we really mean when we talk about IOT
data is time series data some of the
common requirements for storing time
series data include robustness for some
applications data loss simply cannot
happen we want high volumes reads and
writes and we want low latency to go
with these high volumes of reads and
writes we want we want to have efficient
ways of backfill historical data and we
want efficient sequential reads they
connect the devices the producers of the
data we are talking about could be
anything from smart home appliances to
public transit cards whether you're
starting with 10 devices or 10,000 using
the cloud to manage your devices storage
and analytical tooling provides security
reliability and scale I will now hand it
over to Billy and he will talk a little
bit about cloud IOT core cool thanks
Daniel so yeah our cloud-based solution
for this is IOT core and it's you get
secure connections easy ways to manage
your devices and all of this is at
global scale we've got IOT core and then
this breaks down into registries which
are the buckets that hold your
individual devices from there the
registries will automatically connect
and publish messages to a cloud pub/sub
topic and cloud pub/sub is our event
stream manager that will allow your iot
pipelines to scale you get fine-grained
access controls and to end encryption at
at least once delivery to ensure
reliable and secure streaming of data in
a fully managed service and all this is
global by default publish from anywhere
in the
world can consume from anywhere but
consistent latency no replication is
necessary from there pub/sub integrates
perfectly with cloud dataflow our fully
managed stream and batch and batch data
processing tool and you can use this
with the open source Apache beam SDK you
can subscribe to the pub sub topic and
then run your ETL operations on these
messages so this is our IOT pipeline so
far setup your devices on IOT core
they'll send messages to pub/sub and
then your dataflow job will process it
it works great with a handful of devices
and scales up to handle a thousand
megabytes per second we think back to
the example Daniel just showed of those
oil and gas fields around the Gulf of
Mexico those are only adone ly produce
around 15% of what this can handle so
this pipeline can really handle a lot
just to kind of give you that idea for a
scale so we'll take the standard IOT
pipeline and then this is the part where
you of need to make a decision choosing
a storage solution for your data every
database has strings and you have to
make trade-offs to ensure you're using
the database best fit for your use case
Daniel's gonna talk about the features
we'll find in various databases and what
kinds of limitations you might run into
as well Thank You Billy
as Billy showed in the previous slide
the ingestion pipeline is pretty
standardized the moving part here is
storage so in this set section we'll
talk a little bit about the different
characteristics that the databases might
have databases that on the surface will
look pretty similar so if this is too
basic for some of you we apologize for
that but we think it's important that
everybody is on the same page before
moving on so we try to group to deciding
factors for your storage solution into
three pillars functionality sonship such
as data model query languages
partitioning etc scalability which in
the IOT
we'll always will be a deciding factor
and lastly cost let's see if this makes
sense to you
so there are many types of data models
just look at like how many books there
are on data normalization or stuff like
that and every data model comes with
assumptions about how it's going to be
used since the data model has such a
profound effect on what the application
can do or cannot do it's super important
to choose one that is appropriate for
your use case a good practice is to lay
out the queries that you want to be able
to perform on your data ahead of time
that will give you great insights in
what data model to use the relational
model does a very good job of hiding
implementation details behind the clean
interface however the use cases we are
looking at other data models might be a
much better fit let me give you a few
examples so we usually need greater
scalability than what relational
databases easily can achieve especially
when it comes to very large data sets or
ha very high very high right throughput
a desire for more flexible schema design
or a more expressive data model for
example scheming read instead of
scheming right so many people feel that
a declarative language like sequel is
much easier to work with than an
imperative one like JavaScript and as we
discussed previously the relational
model and subsequently sequel does a
really good job of hiding implementation
details of the database engine so that
means that a database vendor can
introduce performance improvements under
the hood without you having to change
any of your queries on the other hand
many known relational databases support
specialized query operations that might
fit our use case much much better one
example would be efficient sequential
reads
and it is in a distributed system or
first we might just address the
terminological conclusion that this is
all the same things it's just what
different databases called shorting or
partitioning or regions or tablets and
whatnot but in a distributed system data
will always be partitioned so when you
have a system with data partitioned over
several nodes how will you go about
scaling your cluster up and down as more
nodes get added to the cluster when the
de database help you reassign data to
new nodes or is that something that you
have to manage yourself and if you have
to manage it yourself will that make you
have to compromise on your scalability
goals in some systems assigning
ownership of a partition to a new node
is a online metadata operation that
doesn't require any online or sorry any
data motion spoiler alert I think Billy
will talk about one of these systems in
a little bit so replication replication
basically means that we are keeping a
copy of the same data on multiple nodes
or multiple machines there are several
reasons why you might like your data
replicated so for once you maybe want to
make sure that your data is
geographically close to your users
another one could be for high
availability reasons maybe you want to
add increase your throughput by adding
additional read replicas or maybe you
want to do it for workload separation
you might have one cluster serving data
and an identical cluster for your
analytical workloads and lastly cost so
how is the database license is it open
source does the provider charge you for
the amount of data that you store order
for the or for the throughput that you
get or something else is it a managed
service do you need to take on
management and monitoring out of the
database and if so how do you quantify
that cost
what does support cost do you have the
competence for this technology in-house
or do you need to train people on it
we did it
hopefully we were on the same page now
and have a common language so if there's
one thing we want you to take away from
this session it is don't treat storage
as an afterthought so we've identified
two different IOT use cases the first
one we call complex application logic
this is where the read to write read to
write ratio is balanced these
applications are not just about
receiving data from devices but also
controlling the devices so the complex
application logic is used to determine
some kind of change that needs to be
performed on the device the other type
of application that we've identified is
what's something we called data
ingestion in intensive here we have many
devices sending a lot of data upstream
these applications are write intensive
as opposed to read intensive and they
are usually used for monitoring or
analytics with that said let's look at a
few scenarios the first scenario we look
at a newly founded IOT startup the IOT
startup is still in the beginning of
their journey so the team is still small
they haven't developed a platform for
smart home appliances like light bulbs
thermostats smoke detectors etc the data
from each smart home appliance is very
suitable to be stored as a
self-contained the document and the
smart home appliances are being
controlled by mobile apps so a family
for example can have several mobile apps
that are controlling these appliances so
let's map these two to two technical
features then small team and a limited
resources most company would probably
benefit from server less today but for a
small small startup it might be
absolutely crucial if you have a small
team of developers letting them focus on
your core business instead of managing
servers could be could make all the
difference self-contained the documents
sounds like something that pretty good
would be a good fit for a document
database the hierarchical
rupture lends itself to good data
locality and the fact that there is
mobile apps that are being used to
control the appliances give us a hint
that this is a complex complex
application logic case so this would be
closer to the first of the two years
case as we discussed earlier so this
startup they don't they don't only face
the challenges of IOT they also have to
manage mobile apps so let's have a quick
look what it would take to build a
mobile database the hard way first you
need a database servers like my sequel
Postgres or [ __ ] and you got to manage
and scale that database yourself then
you want to query the database from afar
so you need an API layer and that API
layer needs to be able to authenticate
and authorize your queries and finally
you need to keep state locally and that
requires yet another database and that
database has to be kept in sync with a
remote one so that's a lot of stuff to
do and that's only to fetch some simple
data and I mean don't let's not even get
started on what it would would take to
make that a real-time system instead of
a polling one let's see how we can
simplify this enter firestore how many
in here are familiar with firestore
that's pretty good
so firestore is what we call a server
less database so a server list doesn't
mean that there are no servers what it
means is that everything from capacity
planning upgrades maintenance all of
that is handled seamlessly by the system
without scheduled downtime multi-region
replication will keep your app and user
data safe available and available across
regions in case of disaster without any
configuration on your side fire store is
a globally distributed database that
will scale based on your usage cloud
fire store lets us structure our data as
collection and documents which makes
queries much easier we can store related
data together in hierarchies we based
this model on what we learned from
firebase real time database developers
we studied how people wanted to model
their data supporting the most common
use cases with patterns that most
developers designed intuitively so far
we noticed that this reduces the
learning curve and that the data model
is designed to scale let's look at
firestore in action
so can we switch to the demo please this
is actually super good this is a live
demo but we have the creator of the demo
in the audience so if if stuff goes
sideways you know so we have four
quadrants here forming the firebase logo
and then we have 40,000 clients that we
have simulated and all these four to ten
10,000 clients are assigned to each of
the quadrants so what we'll do here is
that all these 10,000 clients they are
listening to one of these inputs so and
of course so that no one will get will
get upset we do cero based indexing here
so this is 0 this is 1 this is 2 and
this is 3 so 10000 is listening to each
of these 4 documents when they see a
change they will then write that change
back into this collection which is
called pixels and these are than 40,000
different documents so when we do a
change on one of the documents over here
that will that will trigger 10000 reads
and ten thousand thousand reads from one
document and ten thousand rights to
different documents and hopefully it
will also change the color of this so if
we take this one and we change the color
like this to
and now it should
there you go so we can change it back
like this boom and if you think this is
fake then we can actually look at the
different pixels here so let's switch it
back to red again and now you have to be
focused because it will just flicker
there we go thank you thank you thank
you we can go back to the presentation
thank you and with that I'll wait so
this sounds amazing right firestore so
why would anyone choose another database
over firestorm
maybe Billie can help us answer that
yeah all right thanks Daniel really good
job
glad it worked so yeah all this does
look really good but if you are in so
that's kind of the first case where it's
complex logic but if you're maybe more
in the data ingestion intensive examples
of a use case for IOT
you might need a different solution so
I've got a few examples Russ to look at
that have massive QPS requirements and
solutions that are going to work for
them
the first we're going to take a look at
is for fleet monitoring using IOT so
let's say we are an enterprise scale
company that wants to put some kind of
monitoring device in a fleet of cars or
trucks we'd like to have a dashboard to
monitor our fleet in real time so it
gets good could detect anomalies and
provide feedback to the drivers we'd
also like to do the same with the
historical data store that in the
database and potentially do machine
learning on it and maybe use that to
optimize the fleet or use that to Train
our data so if we translate these needs
into the technical or this business
Easons of the technical requirements we
need the horizontal scalability massive
scale low latency and high throughput
and this is a perfect fit for cloud
BigTable our massively scalable high
throughput globally distributed no
sequel database service and this is the
same technology that powers a range of
billion user Google services we've
proven this to work in search maps and
Gmail and these are applications that
are getting millions of database
accesses per second and it's all
happening with low latency
and if you're thinking a million QPS is
a slow day for you then you can just
increase the performance by adding more
cloud BigTable nodes throughput will
scale linearly based on the number of
nodes so 30,000 QPS for three nodes or
three million QPS for 300 nodes based on
your performance and cost requirements
you can easily scale with no downtime
you don't have to make a sacrifice for
consistent throughput or latency as your
data size grows so we're going to take a
look at two examples here
it's a examples of fleet monitoring I've
had a chance to work with that I think
are pretty cool
the first we're gonna use the standard
BigTable API and then the other leaves
the open-source geo Mesa API so cloud
BigTable provides a ton of raw speed and
scale but does it come with the
trade-off this is a no sequel solution
and with that there's a very minimal
query interface you can do row level
lookups or row range scans and so you
must create a row queue that's gonna
group data together based on the kinds
of queries you want to run for this
example we're looking at monitoring the
New York City bus system and we want to
focus on individual bus lines over time
so we're gonna create a key that's a
concatenation of the bus line the time
stamp rounded down to the hour and then
the vehicle ID and for every data point
within that hour we can store them in
the same row using big tables versioning
feature so with that when we perform a
get row we're getting at all the
information for a vehicle over the hour
and you can see it kinda going across
Central Park but more commonly would
probably use a scan and here we're
getting the entire data set for this for
this m86 select service bus line I'm
looking at the heat map we can already
get a bit of data we can see where the
starts and stops of the bus are and
maybe if there are any SLO points but if
we want to get even more information we
could just append we could change our
query to be half the bus line and maybe
the timestamp rounded up to the month
and then see if that changes over time
we've got a data we've we have a code
lab with all this data that works with
the big table API so and we'll have a
link for that at the end if you want to
play around with this a little bit more
so now I've seen the cloud big table API
but big table also has Apache HBase api
compatibility so you get to use that API
if you're more familiar with HBase and
more importantly this opens up a ton of
additional capabilities for streaming
time series analysis and geospatial
analysis for some of these the
additional API will set up this row key
based schema in a way that will maximize
cloud BigTable speed so you don't have
to do that so and we're gonna take a
look at geo Mesa and this creates a row
key using the latitude longitude and
timestamp to allow for performant
geospatial queries to use it we change
our data flow job to write features
using the geo Mesa API and then we're
able to perform more sophisticated
queries of easily here I've got a query
that's selecting a bounding box on a map
and a time frame and I'm able to do this
with just a few lines of code so Daniel
and I or could this team at Google
that would put air quality sensors in
the back of Google Street View cars and
we were able to stream their data
through our standard IOT pipeline and
set up our dataflow job to write to
BigTable using the Geo Mesa API we were
able to create a speedy dashboard to
view the cars as they drove around San
Francisco in real-time and viewed three
and batch and batch process in three
years of historical data so we're seeing
some of that historical data now and
these are just some of the ways you can
use cloud BigTable as part of your IOT
pipeline now we're going to take a look
at one more IOT scenario and a database
to help out with it here we've got a
large scale or another large scale
organization that wants to create public
transit cards so users can tap their
card on the transit entrance which will
remove money from their card and let
them enter and then if they run out
they'll have to go and refill that
so this is a combination of these IOT
use cases we've our complex logic in
here and this is also very ingestion
intensive so for the business for the
technical requirements for this we need
the horizontals we need a horizontally
scalable system to handle this massive
scale of a public transit system we need
high availability so no one's gonna have
an issue trying to get to their train
and most importantly we need strong
consistency since we're dealing with
monetary transactions and Google's
offering of cloud spanner is great fit
for these it's the first horizontally
scalable strongly consistent relational
database service daniel spoke a little
bit earlier about consistency
availability partition tolerance as some
of the things you might have to choose
between when picking a database now with
most databases you can only have two but
Claude spanner uses special hardware to
allow for all three and Claude spanner
scales similarly per node like cloud
BigTable however to support transactions
with strong consistency rights are going
to be more computationally expensive
than writes without strong consistency
since BigTable doesn't have strong
consistency with amongst rows
so cloud spanner can provide up to 2,000
QPS of rights whereas BigTable comprise
up to 10,000 QPS for writes but really
strong consistency is why that might be
a deciding factor of using spanner over
a big table when you do decide to go
with cloud spanner though you get the
benefits of a relational and
non-relational database on the
relational side you get structure schema
and enforced data types as well as asset
transactions across rows regions and
continents and on the non-relational
side you get the horizontal scalability
of a no sequel database if you're used
to using a single node solution with a
master replicas setup when that system
needs a software update security patch
or any kind of maintenance you may have
to take that system down and have your
users experience downtime we know your
users we know your users and your
services can't have scheduled or
unscheduled
downtime so because spanner is
distributed we can move your data around
to perform routine maintenance under the
hood without any visible changes to you
or your users let's take a look at how
we might use spanner for this public
transit example will define a table that
with using schema should be pretty
familiar to any sequel users and then we
can easily update this schema with no
downtime here we're creating a table of
commuters and their card balances when
we want to perform a transaction on this
we can first get the balance then check
it meets the condition of being greater
than the cost of the fare and then
deduct the cost of the fare from the
balance we've now taken a look at three
IOT scenarios and found databases with
particular strengths that complement the
needs of these applications but these
examples could generate massive amounts
of data so how do you perform analytics
across these ever-increasing data sets
and Daniel's got the answer for that
thank you so we usually divide databases
into OLTP or OLAP systems analytical
queries you usually need to scan over
huge number of Records and calculate
aggregate statistics whereas
transactional queries usually such as a
small number of Records fetched by key
our go-to solution for ad-hoc analytical
workloads is basic bigquery so anyone in
here familiar with bigquery who so
before we do anything else let's do a
super quick bigquery demo can we switch
back today thank you so here we have one
of the public data sets that are
published to bigquery it's the all the
taxi trips in New York well there's
several years but this particular year
is 2015 and here you can see the
different fields that we have and their
data types so I'm just going to do a
super let's say I'm a data scientist at
the city of New York and I want to just
calculate the number of taxi trips per
month
during this year so this is how I would
do that I'll use a time step function
that will I mean it will focus in with
granularity on this is the time stamp
and this the granularity so we want to
pick month from the time stamp and then
we just count the number of trips and
then we group it by month so let's run
this query this is not very big query
it's probably like around 150 million
records and here you see that you get
it's roughly around 12 million 13
million taxi trips per month and if you
want to visualize this it's super simple
everything is a click away by just
importing the data into Data studio so
can we go back to the presentation
things so bigquery serverless the
underlying infrastructure is being
seamlessly managed for you you just
upload your data to bigquery or stream
it into bigquery and bigquery then
provides you with a standard compliant
sequel interface and off you go
it also comes with built-in support for
geospatial and machine learning
capabilities even those capabilities are
expressed through sequel bigquery also
have as a new feature called bi engine
which is a fast in-memory analysis
service traditionally when you use
bigquery you get stable response times
between three to five seconds regardless
almost of how big how many data behave
how many how much data your queries
processing but four so three to five
seconds that's great for a data
scientist but for a dashboard it could
be a little bit much so that's what BA
4 - would be made my want to have
sub-second latency and that's what bi an
engine gives us
all right thanks Daniel so today our
intention isn't to give you all the
answers we want to empower you to know
how to choose a storage system so we
looked at complex logic applications
data ingestion intensive applications
and Daniel just showed us how to perform
and basically analytics on all of those
so take this knowledge and use it to
make an informed decision
don't treat storage as an afterthought
Thank You Jillian I will be around if
you want to chat with us or about this
or any other storage related topics yeah
thanks
[Music]